[Musik]
am tag des lawinenunfall zwar im
gemeindeamt
ich bin in meinem büro am schreibtisch
gesessen haben einen text vorbereitet
und auf einmal ist es dunkel geworden
wir sind hineingeflogen damals nach
landeck und haben dementsprechend mit
der lawinenkommission erste
erkundungsflüge durchgeführt und die
haben dann aus den beobachtungen aus der
luft feststellen kindern dass ein
durchkommen in dieses teil durch die
schneemassen nicht mehr möglich war
die informationen was mir kommt es war
einfach da das eine große lawine in die
ortschaft von galtür hinein gedonnert
ist und das mit mit mit mehreren
verletzten und sogar toten gerechnet
werden muss wie kommen wir hin wenn wir
ein bisschen den clown auf der rechten
talseite auf der linken talseite sind
die ist ausflug kurs
[Musik]
galtür war für uns wie man sie erst
einmal aus der luft entdeckt an ein bild
des schreckens wählen einfach von dieser
ortschaft was früher vorhandenen nichts
mehr eigentlich gestanden ist es war
eigentlich ein weißer teppich über der
ortschaft und es habe vereinzelt in
welche dachgiebel noder gebäudereste aus
diesen menschen die massen hervor
geschaut und das war's
da wir nach der kurzen aber auch wir
angelangt sind haben hatte ich kaufte
mir richtig gesehen was was dort
passiert ist es in der häuser die was
total pulverisiert hat auch das sind
kreuzfeuer klingt sehr viele leute was
verzweifelt gesucht haben es war die
bevölkerung mit teilweise auch urlauber
was da noch mitgeholfen haben wir haben
dann begonnen
in zwei schichten zu arbeiten um 21 uhr
war der wechsel und dann drei unter
flutlicht aus der roboter legte die
nächste teil wieder außer müssen mit
dieser ersten luftbrücke mit diesen
ersten unterstützungskräften die wir
bekommen haben konnten dann auch die
ersten verletzten die im lazarett waren
ausgeflogen werden und es waren dies
unwahrscheinlich wichtiger augenblick
forum jährige türen weil wir auch
gespürt haben jetzt sind wir nicht mehr
allein
[Musik]
doch der durch diese explosion oder taxi
explosionsartige vermischung von von
vielen teilen ist er der wohl sowie
betont der wolf ist
wir haben zuerst die ausländischen
hubschrauber auf der autobahn
entgegengenommen haben sie zu den
diversen landeplätzen in ischgl galtür
geflogen
und wo sie dann selbstständig mit der
evakuierung von den riesen massen an
personen bekommen haben auch sehr sehr
viele kinder an bord waren bei uns und
wenn man dann dort in diese augen
geblickt hat wo dann die erleichterung
zu sehen waren und auch die erschöpfung
wir sind für dieses ausgebildet sind und
natürlich sieht man das nicht gern
meine tochter ist dazu mal zwei
orchestern und wenn man dann
kinderspielzeug weil wir nicht was er
lebt das kind ausgibt auch geborgen
worden aber es ist nicht tot gewesen
es gibt schon zu denken und ist das
bleibt auch wenn er heute noch einen
black pearls erkenntlich den sehr bald
heraus aus den unterschiedlichen
fluggeräusche und viele galtürer
bekommen in diesen momenten oder ganze
halt
[Musik]